la vedette française du salon de l'auto
80,2 sera incontestablement la citroën
bx pour la présentation de cette
nouvelle génération de voitures citroën
a choisi les garrigues en voir les
routes accidentées des cévennes le pont
du gard est aussi question un village
pittoresque avec ses maisons du 13e et
saint-pierre débordante de chaleur et de
couleurs sous le sigle bx citroën
propose une gamme de ses modèles dont un
équipé d'un moteur aluminium de caisse
180 centimètres cubes développant 90
chevaux ce moteur d'une conception
entièrement nouvelle et destiné à
équiper d'autres voitures du groupe 7 7
chevaux dont la ligne pour origine le
carrossier bertone se situe dans la
gamme entre la cx et la gs la bx est une
compacte de quatre mètres ligne droite
très nerveuse avec un habitacle
confortable et une suspension
hydropneumatique hauteur constante
quelle que soit la charge les
techniciens situe sa consommation
moyenne à 6 litres 9 résultats obtenus
par un allègement de la carrosserie et
emploi de matériaux composites la
sécurité bénéficient de nombreuses
innovations par exemple le réservoir en
thermoplastique polyéthylène placé sous
la traverse du siège arrière n'explose
pas en cas d'accident mais fo lentement
les prix de vente varie entre 48 1900 et
59 1800 francs la mise sur le marché de
la bx 900 mille voitures par jour
devrait permettre la création de 6 à 700
emplois à l'usiné de rennes
citroën espère intéresser avec cette
nouvelle ouverture 26 5% des acheteurs
français
cette année pas de
de l'auto mais ça ne va pas empêcher
l'année automobile d'être riche en
nouveautés tf1 vous présentera bien sûr
les modèles les plus intéressants et
aujourd'hui avec éric gilbert nous
découvrons la nouvelle opel kadett la
première traction avant de la general
motors pour en changement c'est un
changement on avait gardé le souvenir
d'une voiture sérieuse mais un peu terne
et aujourd'hui la cadette revient sous
la forme d'une traction avant
accrocheuse
dotée d'une silhouette entièrement revue
et remise au goût du jour
la carrosserie a été réduite de 13 cm le
nouveau modèle présente ainsi une caisse
en deux volumes de moins de quatre
mètres avec un arrière tronqué dans la
lignée de la plupart des européennes de
moyenne cylindrée cette opération
esthétique a permis paraît-il de réduire
sensiblement la consommation
autre innovation sur les versions cher
de la gamme cadette opel propose en 1300
centimètres cubes à culasses d'aluminium
qui développe 75 chevaux est en train de
la voiture à près de 160 kilomètres à
l'intérieur on a gagné de la place
malheureusement les sièges restent dures
et le tableau s'il est complet et d'un
style discutable mais incontestablement
la qualité première de la cadette et sa
tenue de route très franches qui
pardonnera bien des erreurs de conduite
les performances dépendent bien sûr du
moteur choisi
quant aux consommations le constructeur
donne les chiffres suivants 6 litre 4 à
90 km/heure et 9 litres et demi en ville
ce qui est moyen
la gamme est très étendue de 28000 à 38
mille francs on aura le choix entre deux
trois quatre ou cinq portes et aussi
plusieurs breaks
une lacune cependant pour le moment il
n'est pas prévu de version à
transmission automatique
la general motors compte vente 30000
opel kadett dans les 12 mois qui
viennent sur le marché français
deuxième grand de l'automobile
la firme de sochaux n'est pas tout chez
elle par des conflits sociaux pour
l'instant elle joue une partie
importante avec la sortie de son nouveau
modèle la 205 gilles cozanet la 205 que
peugeot commercialisera à partir du 24
février c'est en cas de succès la
planche de salut pour le groupe psa qui
en 1982 a perdu près de 4 milliards de
francs
un pari qui est d'abord un
investissement important 575 millions
pour l'étude de la voiture et 625
millions pour la réalisation des chaînes
de production
un pari ensuite sur le créneau choisi
celui des voitures moyennes qui
représentent 64 % du marché français et
un million deux cent mille véhicules
immatriculés en 1982 la 205 s'attaque en
priorité à la renault 5 à la golf et à
la fiat uno
elle compte aussi mordre sur la ford
escort l'opel kadett la renault 9 et
plus surprenant chez peugeot en tout cas
on s'y attend sur l'a104 vieillissante
et sur l'a350
avec cette voiture peugeot veut frapper
vite et fort en sortant notamment une
gamme complète
sept modèles de la version de base de
quatre chevaux fiscaux à la voiture de
rallye à quatre roues motrices qui
devrait être présenté la semaine
prochaine
fuego avec un nom pareil qui bouscule la
tradition des chiffres renault la régie
avait choisi l'espagne pour présenter sa
gamme de nouveau coupé deux portes
chargé de faire oublier l'échec des 15
et 17
techniquement la fuego bien évidemment
traction avant reprend les bases
techniques de la 18 longueurs 4 mètres
36 avec des améliorations notamment sur
le train avant
d'entrée renault propose en france
quatre modèles en combinant diverses
possibilités deux moteurs 7 et 9 chevaux
3 transmission 4 ou 5 vitesses ou
automatique et 2 degrés de finition
mais deux autres coupé à moteur aux
chevaux seront également lancés à
l'automne et nous avons choisi de vous
présenter le haut de gamme c'est à dire
la version la mieux équipée
cumulant toutes les options tout d'abord
un grand coup de chapeau aux stylistes
qui malgré de sévères contraintes
industrielles ont su réaliser une ligne
originale avec cette ceinture et
plaisante tout en obéissant aux
nouvelles exigences de l'aérodynamique
et pourtant la fuego reste très
habitable en largeur aux coudes comme en
longueur et les places arrière malgré de
petits dossiers sont encore très
acceptable
un effort de présentation fonctionnel
caractérise la planche de bord bien
équipé mais la malle accessible par
cette énorme bulle vitré n'est pas très
grande
moins de 300 litres malgré de petits
coffres annexes et de plus les bagages
reste exposé à la vue par contre le
rabattement différencier des sièges
arrière permet cet agrandissement
souhaitable enfin une grande première
chez renault avec un volant réglable en
hauteur mais aussi une servodirection et
des jantes alliage chaussées de pneus
extra larges très performant
sans qu'il s'agisse d'une désignation
péjorative la série des renault fuego
appartient à la génération des coupes et
ceux de sportifs étroitement dérivée de
berline de série
ceci pour contenir les prix de revient
immédiatement la clientèle dispose d'un
large choix d'où émergent les qualités
traditionnelles de renom le confort
d'abord mais aussi de faible
consommation notamment avec le moteur
sept chevaux
finalement il ressort du comportement
routier de ses voitures
une certaine homogénéité où les
performances pures s'estompe au profit
d'un agrément de conduite paisible
quant aux prix ils varient de 39 milles
800 francs pour la tl sept chevaux de
base à 49 1800 francs pour la gts neuf
chevaux à boîte automatique
on l'attendait avec impatience par
curiosité
la voici tout charme d'or avec les 25
crono prouve que le constructeur
français peuvent aborder le haut de
gamme sans complexe lors de notre essai
la cité partout un vif intérêt à l'arrêt
comme sur la route
incontestablement la ligne réussie
élégante nouvelle ne doit rien à
personne sinon arnaud la r25 dégage une
tranquille assurance fait d'un curieux
mélange à la fois agressive et paisible
fine est robuste et lancer massive 0,28
de cx record battu règle est aussi le
dilemme bicorps ou tricorps la r25 ce
n'est pas un compromis ni une solution
hybride c'est un tout l'intérieur est de
qualité au confort et à l'espace renault
souhaite apporter une nouvelle dimension
la convivialité selon le mot de pierre
tiberghien le passager ne doit plus
subir le transport mais le vivre et
partager le plaisir du conducteur sur la
route leurs 25 et agréable souple
silencieuse la visibilité est excellente
l'électronique embarquée pour reprendre
une expression à la mode est plus
présente que jamais et le vad devenir
vite indispensable
elle permet en tout cas d'avoir un
contrôle constant de tous les organes en
même temps que les principales
informations relatives aux déplacements
le tout sur un tableau de bord panaché
de compteurs classiques à aiguiller
d'indicateurs attestent au liquide côté
mécanique le capot s'ouvre sur un moteur
de ligue 2 pour la gtx injection et
allumage électronique intégral qui
donnera d'ailleurs 123 chevaux à 5250
tours minute
la suspension est à 4 roues
indépendantes frein avec compensateur
boîte 5 vitesses bien étagée le
comportement routier est très simple la
r25 va-vite reste bien assise au sol
elle vire à plat au freinage l'effet
anti plongée et ressenti avec
satisfaction le moteur réagit toujours
bien sur le plan consommation en 1800 km
soit 40 % d'autoroute et 30% de route
nous avons utilisé 190 litres de super
soit une moyenne de dix 8,7 au sens tout
à fait raisonnable compte tenu des
conditions difficiles dans lesquelles
nous avons utilisé cette voiture à
rapprocher des chiffres du constructeur
à noter que l'ordinateur nous a donné 8
litres à 130 kilomètres/heure vitesse
stabilisée et 18 litres à 210 km heure
que ce soit paris melun lyon à 107 km
heure de moyenne nous n'avons pas
dépassé les 18 5
la gamme comporte dès maintenant huit
modèles 4 essence et quatre diesel
elle devrait dès octobre s'enrichir d'un
turbo essence
l'objectif était de 90 milles à cent
mille voitures d'ici la fin 84
actuellement usine de sandouville sort
300 véhicules par jour en juillet on
doit arriver à 6 ans quant aux prix ils
vont de 75 mille francs à 125 mille
francs selon le modèle un bon atout dans
le défi que l'once la régie à ses
concurrents européens